hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a mind-bending
horror and mystery movie called wounds
the movie starts with will a new
orleans-based bartender who works at a
rundown cockroach-infested bar
one evening he is talking to alicia and
her boyfriend jeffrey there is also a
group of college kids playing at
different tables
shortly after wool's friend eric enters
the bar
he looks very drunk and speaks harsh
words regardless of the people around
him the bar gets busier with the arrival
of eric's friends they decide to play
billiards but unexpectedly their game
ends in a fight resulting in eric's
cheek being stabbed in the right side
with a broken glass bottle meanwhile the
group of college kids are filming their
fight
long story short the fight ends because
will tries to separate them
the kids leave the bar in panic and one
of them accidentally leaves his cell
phone at the bar
will takes the phone and brings it with
him when he returns home he approaches
his girlfriend carrie who has fallen
asleep first
after that he is still curious to check
the cell phone
while inspecting it he receives a
message from someone named garrett who
strangely claims that he is scared and
something from the tunnel has been
following him all along the next morning
he has breakfast with carrie
she is suspicious of wolf for carrying
someone else's cell phone he tries to
convince her that it is someone else's
phone that he found at the bar last
night so he confidently gives her the
cell phone
suddenly she is shocked by what she has
found in the cell phone
it turns out that garrett has sent him a
photo that shows a pile of bloody teeth
as the result carrie insists on taking
the cell phone to the police but will
still refuses to give the cell phone for
several reasons
later he drops carry off at her campus
where he suspects her professor is
sleeping with her after that he goes to
eric's house
there he sees a black car in which a
woman is continuously watching him for
no apparent reason he then meets with
eric and sees that his wound is now
infected so will advises him to go to
the hospital but unfortunately he still
refuses it in addition he claims that he
is suffering from nightmares after last
night's fight we'll also spot some sort
of inhuman flesh in eric's wound
since eric refuses to be cured will
decides to get out of there and go
shopping
in the store he sees alicia and her
boyfriend from a distance
it is revealed that he has a crush on
her and envy's jeffrey
on his way home he doesn't notice that
one of the college kids is following him
around the town
at home he is shocked to discover photos
and videos on the phone of a corpse and
decapitated head being surrounded by
cockroaches
not long after carrie comes home and she
is confused while still keeps the cell
phone
she then also sees the strange footage
and forces will to hand it over to the
police
moreover she accidentally discovers a
book in one of the photos entitled the
translation of wounds
at the end they cull garrett and hear an
inhuman screeching on the other end
while driving to the police station will
receives messages from another member of
the group stating that he has been
chosen because he called earlier
later he spots one of the college kids
following him he then hallucinates the
phone turning into a cockroach creature
and throws it out the car window he gets
out of the car and cleans his hands
until he rolls over
the people around record the incident
and the opportunity is used by one of
the kids to pick up the cell phone he
immediately chases them but his effort
is in vain
after that he goes to the police station
and tells everything that has happened
unfortunately the police cannot do
anything without the phone
soon will hangs out with alicia and they
eventually make out before alicia stops
because she feels guilty
therefore he drives alicia home with an
awkward moment he then receives strange
texts from carrie and drives home
straight away
there he discovers carrie is staring at
a strange video of a tunnel in a trance
she states that she doesn't remember
sending all the strange texts and go
straight to sleep
later that night will awakens and finds
garrett is in the house
he strangely throws up a pile of teeth
before claiming he and his friends
summon something it possessed them and
will has now brought it into his own
home
at that time it sees him as the perfect
vessel
the next day will hallucinates a
cockroach crawling out of a wound in his
armpit consequently he immediately
cleans it and subconsciously rubs his
armpit until it bleeds he and carrie
start to get more distant and aggressive
to one another he discovers that she has
been searching for garrett online as
well as the books she noticed in the
photo and gnostic rituals
it states that a wound is a portal for
the higher beings to enter the world
at work will gets more and more erratic
to his customer
after a while jeffrey and alicia come to
the bar as usual but jeffrey looks very
angry because he already knows that will
is trying to take alicia from him he
ends up fighting with will
fortunately his friend is able to
separate them he then receives another
text from kerry claiming that someone is
in the house with her a panicked will
rushes home and eventually discovers her
in a trance again
she is in a catatonic state that does
not stop until she is bathed which
results in a strange dark liquid washing
off her in the bathtub
the next morning will and carrie break
up
she accuses him of being empty and
unfriendly will doesn't accept this and
says that it's all caused by the
mysterious cell phone
unfortunately she doesn't care about it
and ends up with will leaving her crying
alone at home
he goes to work and his temper is
getting out of control he vents his
frustration on unimportant things and
also snaps at his boss resulting in him
quitting he then calls alicia
desperately to express all his feelings
to her and says that he already broke up
with carrie
dejectedly she says that she still loves
jeffrey and tells him to stop calling
her
feeling broken and alone he decides to
stay at eric's house
on the other hand eric's wound has
worsened he also reveals the college
kids forced him to lure will to the
house and they asked him to give will a
present will spots and are looking at
him through eric's wound he discovers
the phone in eric's possession and is
prompted to accept the present wrapped
in flesh
he realizes that the higher beings the
kid summoned earlier are inside eric's
wound
after calling garrett again the room
fills with the inhuman screeching and a
swarm of cockroaches arrive will finally
submits and starts to absorb the higher
being in an attempt to become whole as
cockroaches envelop the house
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching